and I know you because you're from my
hometown Richard Ramirez Night Stalker
you just died of cancer in your cell a
few years back so that was a birdís back
biches and she wants to play some strip
pictionary yes another season of
American Horror Story has come it's so
sad and think story is here to break
down the final episode and I gotta say I
really enjoyed this season I know the
camp eNOS get it isn't everyone's cup of
tea but overall I got a rank this in my
top three seasons that being said don't
form a mob or anything but the final
episode for me left a lot of unanswered
questions and there were some character
arcs that weren't fully fleshed out and
lots of plot inconsistencies so I may do
one of my how it should have ended
videos if I have time in the upcoming
days if you haven't seen the one I did
for last season's apocalypse I've left a
link in the description below we are
back at Camp redwood this time in 2019
an uber drives Bobby Richter yes the now
adult son of mr. jingles to the
abandoned camp which hasn't been touched
since that ill-fated fire festive I mean
camp redwood festival back in 1989
Bobby passes a rusted wood chipper
foreshadowing the kick-ass gore that's
to come we can see by the entrance sign
this place has seen better days and even
the stage hasn't been touched I'm still
a little bitter we didn't get to see
Evan Peters as Billy Idol Bobby takes
pictures with his cell phone when
Montana appears who asks him what that
device is no one has really visited the
place since 89 so she wouldn't know what
a cell phone is when he tells her he's
the son of jingles who's come looking
for answers she gives him a hug as we'll
find out Montana has turned a new leaf
killing isn't her priority at least not
anymore
just be careful what you say around her
Bobby aerobics is kind of a joke these
days what did you say taking Bobby to
the cabin we also see that Trevor's
there he has survived his tragic dick
shooting which we'll get to in a bit
Bobby has a scrapbook filled with
information about the camp including all
of its victims
he tells Montana that his aunt on her
deathbed told him the truth about his
father that's why he's now all of a
sudden ventured to the camp in search of
aunts
thirty years later he's also the
luckiest person on the planet receiving
anonymous checks from someone and wants
to find out who sent them unfortunately
for Bobby the ghost of jingles hasn't
been seen Montana saying that she saw
with her own eyes him being taken away
by dark forces she's referring to him
being thrown overboard by the drowned
deformed corpse of his brother the one
he was supposed to be looking after but
instead was perving some counselors
making sexy time Montana grabs Bobby's
gun from his backpack to prove that she
can come back to life that's like a
great party trick when we're transported
back to 1989 margaret is pissed because
the talent is nowhere to be found
she's chilling with Ricky and Bruce and
when Kourtney comes in telling her that
Trevor has blocked the road she shoots
him in the face so disrespectful after
he cleaned up that entire tour bus and I
think the only thing more offensive than
Trevor's shirt is this dude's troll hair
at the entrance to Redwood trevor has
slashed the tires of what appears to be
catch a goo goos tour bus he's done with
putting up with Margaret's crap and
proclaims to his wife his undying love
for Montana but Margaret won't let him
get away with this she shoots him not
just in the chest but in the dick that's
got to hurt I don't care where you're
from and if getting shot in the dick
wasn't terrifying enough he was shot
over the property line meaning if he
dies he won't resurrect as one of the
ghosts Montana appears but she too is
helpless she can't cross the line to
save him but it's Brooke who comes to
save the day
she's turned a new leaf after almost
killing the journalist last episode and
has embraced the good side helping
Trevor over the line back in present-day
Montana catches Bobby up to speed on
what happened to Margaret Bruce and of
course the night stalker himself
Ricky Ramirez the ghosts ended up
banding together to put a stop to them
even using midge this character here who
you might remember as one of the
original 1970 massacre victims as a
decoy to kill Bruce I also love how he
holds the knife here because he has no
thumbs
Trevor stabs Bruce and kicks him outside
the bounds of the property so he won't
be able to resurrect Ramirez however is
a different story they just can't kill
him and chuck them off the property
because he'll just resurrect by the
power of singing and
off to kill Bobby that missed you too
but the festival seems like a bust so
I'm gonna go kill this kid in Alaska
Montana's plan is to set up a Death
Watch lure Ramirez into lavinia Shack
and repeatedly murder him every time he
resurrects until the end of time I mean
I guess the alternative was to let him
go but since Montana says there are tons
of ghosts there they can take turns
Xavier uses a chainsaw and Ray even
unleashes his inner Annie Wilkes by
hobbling his legs with a sledgehammer
and I will say Ramirez death is probably
the goriest death we've seen in ages to
date like I'll get demonetised if I even
try to show it as Montana says the ghost
took up mr. jingles mantle protecting
Bobby in the world from the evil that is
Ricky Ramirez we then are sent 20
minutes earlier where birdy puts the
moves on [ __ ] leaving Ricky unattended
but the thing that's even more
far-fetched than this scenario is the
fact that tonight of all nights
Ricky escapes not just once but twice
after 30 years Ricky attacks Bobby by
throwing this huge ass knife into his
back I mean look at it and I love how he
just kind of forgets he has a giant
life-threatening gash in his back the
next few scenes at the asylum
Ricky really wants to kill Bobby as
payment for his dad's betrayal of both
himself and Satan saying that he needs
to pay his debt but Bobby is saved yet
again by the ghost and told by Montana
to go to the red Meadows asylum now this
is also the last we see Ricky which was
kind of a letdown for me I guess we're
to assume that the ghosts once again
continued their death watch uh-oh guys
who's on death watch
Bobby arrives at red Meadows this same
hospital where his father was kept and
had been subjected to electroshock
therapy
Bobby strolls in looking like a hobo and
just expects to speak to the director at
what is probably 11 o'clock at night
Bobby how do you think this is gonna go
down
then these orderlies come in and take
him away which i think is illegal but
whatever I'm here for it when he
mentions his father's name a name which
Donna chambers the now medical director
recognizes it's kind of ironic that
she's the director since she was the one
who orchestrated jingles escape from
that very institution way back in 84 she
tells him Margaret was the real killer
and
it's her story the angry mob of ghosts
have surrounded the cabin while Margaret
loads her gun but it's Donna who's the
first to take a stab at her literally
Brooke comes to save the day but in the
scuffle is shot we'll get back to her in
a second Margaret has brought out to the
wood chipper where her limbs are
systematically cut off one by one it's
only fitting that Trevor gets to call
the shots here as revenge for his
elephant truck getting shot any friggin
Kobe's her head into the chipper now
it's really easy to miss because it
happens really fast but when her head
which Montana says can live 30 seconds
after being decapitated is thrown into
the chipper the wind blows her guts back
onto the redwood property which is why I
guess she was able to resurrect Donna
tells Bobby that she was the final girl
that Brooke died that night but if Donna
wasn't the one sending him checks who
was it they're able to locate the post
office by tracing the routing number
found on the checks which leads them all
the way to Oregon it's there they find
Brooke is still alive not only that but
she has her own family her own normal
life now Emma Roberts is supposed to be
like 5060 years old here and I love how
they try to brush off that she doesn't
look old by saying her husband is a
dermatologist okay Donna is upset and
for a good reason
she's carried this guilt with her for 30
years that she was responsible for
Brookes death and I gotta be honest
Brookes response that it was just too
hard for her was kind of weak we find
out that Rey was the one who helped
Brooke out the bullet went right through
her and says he'll get some bandages ray
you're probably gonna need a lot more
than bandages for this one however I
forgive it because they do this cute
iodine and bandage
which is a nod to their first somewhat
romantic encounter back in Episode one
ray leads her to the edge of the
property and all she remembers is
passing out and waking up in a hospital
and somehow the tour bus that was
blocking the way has magically been
removed
Brooke sent checks to Bobby as her way
of coping with what had happened she
said she needed a glimmer of hope in all
the darkness she had seen that at once
evil man could find Redemption
turn his life around and start a family
and be a good person she also knows how
camp redwood has a way of pulling people
back
perhaps if Bobby was given money he
could break free from this quote awful
legacy Brooke and Donna turn out to be
the final girls and I gotta be honest I
thought Brookes ending was pretty weak
considering they built her up to be
probably the closest to a main character
this season but let me know what you
guys think in the comments below outside
Brookes Bobby tells Donna that he has to
go back to redwood that he felt
something when he was there
I guess Brooke was right that the camp
really does have a way of pulling people
back in it's at redwood that Bobby meets
Margaret who survived her trip to the
wood chipper she says she's the only one
who knows where his father is how she
knows this is never explained maybe
she's lying I don't know
and later when jingles appears before
Bobby we never get a clear answer how he
magically shows up this to me is one of
the more frustrating aspects of the
season the rules surrounding the whole
curse and resurrection stuff is
conveniently twisted so that the writers
can adjust it to fit whatever plot point
they're trying to achieve for example in
some episodes the bodies take time
before they're resurrected and in others
they magically appear moments later
jingles isn't able to be found for 30
years but then comes out at the end
where was he when Bobby first arrived
where was jingles this whole time some
were at the camp or in his own personal
heaven as I fear eyes din my episode 8
video all of this is very muddy but I
still liked how Bobby was able to
finally meet his dad in grandma jingles
ask jingles Jr why he came back and he
says it was to thank him for the
sacrifice his father made so that he
could grow up and be free without the
specter of Ricky after him Lavinia is
the one to kill Margaret which is kind
of ironic since Lavinia was the first
massacre perpetrator killing Margaret
who's the second and third the ghost say
farewell to Bobby and Montana talks
about how the 80s will never die just
like themselves with the final scene
taking place between Bobby and his
family his grandmother father and uncle
Bobby I'll get more into this if I end
up doing a how it should have ended
video but the thing that disappointed me
the most was the lack of closure for the
ghosts specifically a few of them who
had cool backstories and traumas that
were explored yet their redemptive arcs
were never really panned
I would also have loved to have seen
more lore behind the curse surrounding
the camp and tie-ins to other seasons I
think they missed a valuable opportunity
to tie Rickie in with Michael Langdon
and last season's apocalypse they have
so many similarities yet that was all
glossed over overall though this season
was fun as hell I don't think there was
a dud episode in the bunch as much as I
throw shade at the show I do it out of
love so I hope you'll consider stab and
that like button subscribing and leaving
a comment about what you thought about
the season you can also follow me on
Twitter at think story whitey until next
season remember daddy loves you very
much